qu'erica tricot infirmier anesthésiste à
l'hôpital henri mondor de créteil
syndicat sud-santé bonsoir élites que
ricco merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous avez participé à la
manifestion manifestation aujourd'hui
que demandez vous concrètement j'ai
surtout participer j'ai surtout
accompagner les personnels taurea qui
était effectivement en colère qui sont
désabusés pour certains qui ont été
unifiés par un mépris de ce gouvernement
vous ce qu'on demande c'est de répondre
positivement aux trois revendications
qui sont ils nous ont motivés depuis
maintenant certain nombre de mois on ne
peut pas bien certain nombre d'années
c'était une augmentation et un
recrutement à hauteur des besoins en
personnel mais aussi en moyens matériels
et puis surtout une revalorisation
salariale sur des salaires qui sont
gelés depuis trop longtemps
olivier et veyran a présenté les axes de
son plan il ya des mesures qui semblent
être retenu les augmentations de
salaires pour les personnels soignants
le plan d'investissement et la remise en
question des 35 heures ça c'est un autre
sujet on en parlera
il ya des choses quand même là dedans tu
lis peuvent vous rassurer absolument pas
absolument pas parce que jusqu'à présent
c'est une ce ne sont que des promesses
ces ondées contre on a l'impression que
ce gouvernement découvre la
problématique dans les hôpitaux publics
c'est quand même assez hallucinant alors
moi j'entends les rémunérations
augmentation de l'année des salaires
très bien mais à quelle hauteur je vous
rappelle quand même que monsieur les
rangs à communiquer dans le journal du
dimanche ce week-end on dit l'anc ont
ils allaient se baser sur la moyenne
européenne à la moyenne européenne que
l'on veut monsieur macro n'arrête pas de
dire qu' il est pour les premiers de
cordée nous sommes les premiers de
cordée actuellement nous sommes nous
avons été applaudi par des milliers de
gens par des millions de
d'autres en fait nous estimons être les
premiers de cordée mais il faut pas nous
mettre à la moyenne de l'europe avec
largement au dessus je rappelle quand
même que nous sommes actuellement un des
meilleurs systèmes de santé au monde et
pourtant le personnel soignant et payer
et payer de façon complètement
dérisoires et indécentes puisque nous
sommes 26e sur 29 pays au niveau du
classement ocde
quand vous dites on est l'un des
meilleurs santé au monde est ce que
c'est un postulat qui est toujours
valable à ce que cette liste du comique
19 n'a pas démontré que ce n'était plus
le cas
ben moi je crois qu'au contraire elle a
démontré la solidarité entre différents
corps de métier qui a fait justement
face un système de santé que l'on tombe
bien un qui est que ces gouvernements
tant celui de macron que celui de
hollande temps vers une privatisation à
outrance
si la solidarité envers comment de tous
ces corps de métiers n'avait pas
fonctionné correctement
ça aurait été une catastrophe sanitaire
et la preuve c'est que monsieur véran et
d'autres communicants de ce gouvernement
l'ondé on est passé très près de la
catastrophe sanitaire et cette
catastrophe sanitaire elle a été déjoué
parce que justement les personnels ont
remonté les manches et on sait ils ont
fait front sauf que je rappelle quand
même que le président c'est le chef
suprême des forces armées en france
lui il a envoyé son élite militaire à
savoir les personnels soignants il est
envoyé au front sans moyens de
protection ça ça a été inactive il
acceptable
c'est ce qui fait de mettre la goutte et
le feu aux poudres
là il vient à la salpêtrière pour offrir
quoi pour nous dire on va vous remettre
une médaille et c'est inutile ce site du
monde sait y mettre
finalement lors leurs propositions
qu'ils font c'est s'aider pansement sur
une jambe de bois
moi j'attends ce jeu pour l'instant j'en
aurais rien voir venir je rappelle quand
même que toutes les primes trou était
fait et promise en tout cas par ce
gouvernement on n'en voit pas la queue
on en voit rien du tout moi je suis
excessivement mission et je vais de
toute façon on va notre mauvaise
surprise des surprises avec ce
gouvernement
alors olivier ferrand qui a évoqué les
35 heures
aujourd'hui avec leur remise en cause on
sait très bien que vous travaillez dans
les hôpitaux plus que 35 heures quelle
est votre réaction par rapport à cette
proposition en tout cas de les remettre
en cause des 35 heures écoutez je vais
assumer ce que je veux dire
jusqu'à présent les gouvernements quand
ils veulent faire passer une loi alors
que toute l'opinion publique solel ils
la feront passer en force avec le 49-3
moi j'ai ce sentiment amer mais je ne
suis pas le seul on est tous à avoir ce
sentiment et quand je dis tous c'est
tous les personnels hospitaliers aussi
bien le personnel paramédical que le
personnel médical
on a l'impression qu'ils se servent du
cas du communisme voyage on disait ça
hydro dictateur biya les gouvernements
et edouard philippe sonnet de service du
49 3 maintenant ils ont leur lisons le
communisme c'est hallucinant dans un
sort à corps de métier qui a autant
donner pendant deux mois qui s'est
épuisé on a quand même des collègues qui
en sont morts et là il nourrit nous
disent écoutez on va se baser sur
l'allemagne et travaillent effectivement
ils ont des meilleurs salaires de goût
mais travaille plus donc on va vous
remettre à des taux horaires haut lieu
on va animer les 35 heures non non s'ils
ont su correctement le jeu des 35 heures
et sida les embauches derrière il ya
suffisamment de quoi faire il ya
suffisamment de d'ouverture pour laisser
les 35 heures est embauchée sauf que
c'est une stratégie politique il faut
aller chercher les misères dans les
paradis 6o dans les paradis fiction
pardon mais c'est aussi de ses voeux
c'est aussi l'impôt sur la grosse
fortune comme par exemple on n'entend
jamais parler
il ya des milliards en france ils ne
sont pas roses nuit dans l'est dans les
endroits stratégiques que sont les
services publics et là en l'occurrence
l'hôpital public
non il ya une autre stratégie qui est ni
plus ni moins que donner de l'argent par
départ des dividendes et par les gros
patrons du cac 40
dernière question la france pourra
recourir au plan de relance européen
pour rénover l'hôpital c'est bruno le
maire qui le dis ce soir ça pourrait
quand même on a bien compris que vous
n'êtes pas d'où confiance du tout au
gouvernement mais ce que ça serait de
nature à vous rassurer tout même que ça
passe par l'europe
honnêtement je ne suis là je suis je
suis pas sûr que de passer par l'europe
ça soit une si bonne une si bonne chose
après voilà ça n'engage que moi mais je
sais pas quand je vois certains pays
comme la grèce ont été mis à trépas et
c'est l'europe qui indique qu il est
derrière
est-ce que derrière il ya un repas des
spéculations sans système de santé et
sur la sécurité sociale voyez tout
l'écrin font qu' il y aura il ya des
interrogations il ya des craintes du
personnel soignant mais aussi par des
politiques qui ont qui ont besoin et
qu'ils ont en tout cas qui vont oeuvrer
pour que le service public et l'hôpital
public reste un joyau de notre
institution donc voyons voir attendons
regardons mais avec la plus grande
vigilance et la plus grande méfiance en
tout cas ça c'est une certitude
et vous l'avez dit en introduction il ya
une ou deux doses pour la franquette
arrêté qu est le 16 juin
quoi qu'il arrive plan d'urgence ou pas
sanitaires on ira dans la boue et on ira
faire du bruit on ira chercher notre dû
là maintenant monsieur macron doit se
rend bien compte qu'il ya quand même
toute la classe populaire et tout sous
les ponts celles qui sont derrière les
personnels soignants on a touché du
doigt cette défaillance du système
française sanitaire et ben maintenant un
moule à nous d'être les premiers de
cordée et nous sommes les premiers deux
camps merci eric tricot d'avoir été avec
nous en direct